[Musique]
emmanuel grenier bonjour bonjour
monsieur cas où vous êtes candidat pour
les prochaines élections municipales au
gros morne
alors c'est pas la première fois que
vous participez à une campagne
électorale le emmanuel grenier alors
pourquoi avoir décidé de tenter une
nouvelle expérience et cette fois pour
essayer d'être mère du gros morne
en fait ce qui m'intéresse surtout c'est
le bien être des gones est alors c'est
sûr que comme tous les candidats il
faudra parler du marché de l'église du
terrain de football
mais moi je crois que le groupe vit une
situation catastrophique depuis un
certain nombre d'années les deux
dernières mandatures ne sont pas de très
bonnes mandature vous les gones est
singulièrement celle celle là qui est en
train de s'achever lorsque je vois les
temps du goût monde lorsque je vois
l'état des 46 et lorsque je vois les
projets qui a pas de projets y a pas de
projets donc je m'étais dit que j'allais
me retirer de l'action politique mais
finalement sincèrement je crois qu'on ne
peut pas rester insensible à ça et c'est
pour ça qu'avec mon équipe j'ai décidé
de me représenter
et si les gones et le veulent bien géré
cette commune
alors appelez nous justement le nom de
votre liste legault monde tout
simplement
le roman tout simplement mais vrai
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser que cette
fois là vous avez une réelle chance de
pouvoir gagner peut-être mais je pense
simplement je pense que c'est surtout vu
l'état de la commune je crois que les
gonesse ont déçu bon je n'ai rien contre
le maire personnellement je n'ai rien
contre les candidats personnellement
mais je crois que les gonesse sont
véritablement déçu de détendre la
commune si vous passez dans des
quartiers du gourmand nous voyez que
deux voitures ne peuvent même pas
s'entrecroisent et les piétons sont
obligés de marcher dans la rue c'est
quand même catastrophique et par contre
j'entends çà et là ce que les candidats
disent mais je voudrais quand même
rectifier quelque chose à votre micro
monsieur caruge ici même j'ai entendu
monsieur vosges ive ans qui disait que
tous les anciens qui s'était présenté en
2004 se sont réunis pour voter pour lui
pour être le candidat de ces gens là je
m'inscris en faux parce que je ne
faisais pas partie de sal jamais été
convoqués à cette réunion et monsieur
bertrand pirlouit qui est lui aussi
candidat
donc finalement je m'inscris en faux
bond et je suis un petit peu embêté
c'est que cette campagne démarre déjà
sur des mensonges
lorsque j'entends toujours à votre micro
j'entends monsieur raphaël vous j'y vais
en parler du plus que catastrophique
mais enfin ce plu a commencé à être
initiés j'étais dans l'opposition à
l'époque avec monsieur albert joseph il
est maire et monsieur rafael vigilant
qui était adjoint au maire
lorsque j'entends ça on dimanche sur des
mensonges tournoi je voudrais quand même
alors confié ça très bien vous avez
rectifier mais comme monsieur vaugirard
est déjà passée qu'il pourra pas
repasser pour vous répondre
donc on pourra pas être trop long sur
non non je suis souvent je voulais
simplement ce n'est pas exact j'ai
entendu ça sur votre chaîne alors
emmanuel grenier si vous êtes élue maire
du gros-morne là en mars 2020 quelques
années le dossier que vous souhaiteriez
attaqué en priorité qu'est ce qu'il ya
de plus urgent du point de vue de la
municipalité un même pour pour le maire
que vous seriez d'accord moi je pense
que les gones et lorsqu'ils paient leurs
impôts ils souhaitent avoir un certain
nombre de choses dans leur commune alors
ne serait ce que des choses toutes
simples le bien-être le vivre ensemble
alors on va pas venir confère une tour
lui mina mais on va s'occuper
on s'occupera des auteurs s'occupera des
abondé watch mais on s'occupera aussi je
vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure la de
l'église éventuellement parce que
l'ancolie glisse ça fait plus de 12 ans
que l'église est fermée et j'entends des
candidats ça et là d'où je m'occuperai
de l'église qui étaient eux aussi
candidats déjà dont le terrain de
football le réveil sportif le marché du
goût mais aujourd'hui les gens vont
leurs marchandises à même le sol ça ce
sont des actions qu'il faudra de toute
façon qu'on en compte mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est surtout aux dépens
je me rappelle quand j'étais gamin les
entrées du bourg du gaumont n'était
flury quelle que soit la route par
laquelle nous arrivions au monde vous
avez une commune agréable
c'était le grenier de la martinique
cette commune le goût montrent qu'une
ville agricola à donner à manger à la
martinique et ce n'est plus le cas selon
lui le cas mais ce n'est plus la can one
no nos agriculteurs sont obligés d'aller
aux manants 7 maryvonne leurs produits
il n'y a pas de marché a pas de
structure ni des phrases cultes
youpougon monde moi je pense que ce sont
des choses importantes à its habillée
très rapidement mais je crois que bon
bien sûr on fait le reste 30 secondes on
ne connaît pas on ne connaît pas l'état
d'aider on connaît pas l'état des
finances et seulement si le peuple nommé
aux affaires conçois ma foi nous dit on
fera un audit financier mais on voit
ainsi un audit pour voir le côté
management avec le les administratifs et
des employés de la mairie pour voir un
certain nombre de choses mais je pense
que ce qu'il faut pour le moment c'est
avoir une vision sur 15 10 15 ans merci
emmanuel granier bien sûr qu'un sujet à
sa occasion le rappelle vous êtes
candidat
donc pour l'élection municipale au gros
mort merci
[Musique]